Let me give you an image that's a
cliche,
but it's an image.
John Wayne.
Oh God.
Couldn't we start with someone easier?
Let me ask you a question.
Has John Wayne ever been at a loss of
words?
Seriously,
go watch your favorite John Wayne
Classic and pay attention to how he
speaks over his 40 year career
regardless of his age,
character,
or mood.
He almost always talks,
but the same.
Iconic masculine confidence and control.
He always has the right thing to say in
as few words as possible.
Envelope.
That'll be the day even when he's angry,
he's not really angry.
He never loses his cool.
He never stammered screams or even
improvises.
Lost my temper in 40 years,
but pilgrim,
you caused a lot of trouble this
morning.
Might've got somebody killed somebody
out a belt,
chewing them out.
Even at his worst.
He doesn't lose that cool John Wayne
presence,
and there's actually something amazing
about that ability,
and I'm not saying this makes him a bad
actor.
Actually,
many studio Hollywood actors had a
limited vocal range.
Whether Humphrey Bogart was a private
investigator.
Actually,
Jack,
if he didn't eat a nightclub owner where
I'm going,
you can follow what I've got to do.
You can be any product or even an
Irishman.
I would hoping that maybe in the state
of mind,
he always had his trademark voice.
It explains why some actors at that time
are so easy to imitate it.
You got any girlfriends at the same
problem bringing them over and John
Wayne is no exception.
The John Wayne still seems to stand out.
His complete control.
His whole persona has an almost mythic
quality to it,
so you're a men's only good for one node
at a time.
It's as if he's created a certain idea
for masculine authority through his
voice.
There's an idea of talking like John
Wayne,
but post-classical method acting ushered
in a wave of chameleon.
Actors like Marlin Brando,
Robert De Niro,
and Meryl Streep,
actors who morphed to their voices and
disappeared into their roles.
Any attempt at imitating Daniel Day,
Lewis would probably result in simply
imitating one of his characters,
not the actual actor,
because he does them all so differently.
The use of complex voice acting not only
created more immersive performances,
but actors and directors now use voice
in more complicated ways to tell their
story.
It's not always about what a character
says,
but how and when they say it,
voice shows the characters control of a
scene or their lack of control.
I want to use voice acting as a means
for analyzing one of the most
complicated characters in film.
Daniel,
plainview in there will be blood and I
think to understand Daniel plainview,
you have to first understand talking
like John Wayne.
Get off your heart and head into the
Solo.
John Wayne's big break came in 1939 in
stagecoach and his introduction starts
his streak of vocal control right from
the beginning.
John Wayne has a mastery of voice after
a long montage of stage coach ride and
he's the one that can stop the entire
narrative with a single command and
notice what else is going on.
In his introduction shot,
he immediately establishes himself as a
master of his own movement through his
flashy gun turn,
the epic pushing of the camera toward
his face and the mythical quality of the
background like he manifested out of the
West.
Here we see fearlessness and mastery and
the whole film stops to accommodate him.
The remainder of the scene presents
another interesting phenomenon.
Invoice in 1939 editors.
We're still tinkering with how to cut
dialogue and the camera would stay on a
character most or all the time they were
talking except for John Wayne.
In this scene,
you'll notice he's the only character
that talks while the camera focuses on
other characters and they expect to see
you riding shotgun on this run.
Marshall,
as he talks,
it cuts to reactions or he talks away
from the camera as he approaches the
stage coach.
Even in his first big movie,
even as Ringo,
the kid,
and even right at his character
introduction,
his voice could control the movement all
on its own.
He has an almost directorial influence
on the story.
There's a distinct power to talking
without being seen in the same way that
a narrator of a story has a godlike
quality to them.
If they talk,
well,
not interviewed,
that means they're still controlling the
scene even when they aren't there.
In John Wayne's introductory scene,
we see two methods of showing control,
directing the narrative through voice
and controlling the camera,
and he's not the only one to control
this wet,
please.
We actually also here Daniel plainview,
before we see him speaking,
I've traveled over half our state like
John Wayne.
He shows narrative control in his
character introduction.
He establishes he's the only one
qualified to drill,
and when people try to interrupt his
narrative,
he ignores them.
What is your offer?
We're wasting time.
I do my own drilling.
His authority does get challenged when
the crowd uproars,
but he simply leaves changing the
narrative to what he wants.
Refusing to not have total control.
No,
no,
no.
There's no confusion.
Doesn't take the leash
and controls the movement of the camera.
It stops when he stops.
It moves.
When he moves after another voice of God
transition,
we see him get elise.
How he wants shifting the conversation
to be about family,
to win them over.
Another way to show control in a movie
is through controlling the voices of
others.
This can be as simple as regulating when
people talk
or regulating what they're allowed to
say,
man,
we
associate what people say with what
they're thinking,
what they believe in,
and what they want.
If you control what someone can say,
you control everything about them.
Shame my name.
In any scene,
a character's voice can show control in
these factors,
how voice directs the narrative,
how the voice controls the shot,
and how characters control the voices of
others.
It's usually a combination of the three
double you motherfucker.
In reality,
everybody wishes they had the control of
voice like John Wayne.
Even when people disagree with him,
he still drives the narrative and it has
complete mastery of the world around
him.
He may sometimes be a flawed hero,
but the floor is never in his voice,
so we always had some level of control.
In Red River,
he gets betrayed,
but his voice makes it clear that he'll
end up with what he wants.
Every time you turn around and expect to
see me one time,
you'll turn around and I'll be there,
but the problem with John Wayne's
authority,
it never gets questioned.
Even when he loses,
he still talks in that confident air,
never completely losing his mastery of
the world of the West.
What makes there will be blood so well
written is how carefully each scene
tests,
power dynamics through voice and Daniel
Plain fuse iconic presence does get
challenged in inventive ways to the
point where the film seems to question
whether or not a John Wayne like vocal
control is ever possible or even
desired.
Daniel plainview actually gets a pretty
worthy opponent in the film.
Eli Sunday is a gifted orator and he
constantly questions playing views,
vocal authority.
Do you started to
take a seemingly benign conversation?
Plainview has with Eli Sunday.
What appears to be Eli,
just making a simple request is actually
a carefully coated fight for vocal
control.
Eli starts with some innocent Chit Chat,
which plain view doesn't engage in
spirit seem high.
Then Eli chooses to see himself without
being offered.
Here we see Eli taking initiative,
contrasting his brother's politeness in
an earlier seed.
Can I sit down please?
The scene becomes about vocal control.
When Eli asks to speak at the induction
of the well,
I will bless the.
Well actually he doesn't ask.
He says he will directing the speech as
he wants it.
Before you begin,
you should introduce me.
Of course,
plainview correction,
but Eli ignores his correction.
You'll see me walk up.
He even provides him a script and then
you could say the proud son of these
hills who tended his father's flock,
plainview bates,
him letting him pick the time.
Well,
let's make it 4:00 then and then it cuts
to the actual induction where Eli is
supposed to speak,
but plainview directs it his way,
pulling up the little girl and
performing his own script.
He does it all on his own.
Ignoring Eli's request.
The camera hovers on Eli as plainview
blesses the well and his voice of God
dominates the scene,
and Eli,
he even manipulated Eli's words and
makes them his own number one name for
the lovely ms dot every Sunday here by
my side,
a proud daughter of these hills and a
simple sequence plain view gives up the
win.
Let's Eli's guard down and deans back
control of directing the moment how he
wanted controlling the camera and
controlling Eli's words,
but Eli shouldn't be underestimated as a
character.
He speaks very well and is the vocal
leader of the town.
It's two directors pitted against each
other.
One directs the congregation.
The other directs the oil.
The next focal showdown between the two
comes in Eli's territory.
When plain view has to get baptized.
Notice Eli already starts in control.
When we hear his voice,
before we see him speak,
I truly wish everyone could be saved.
Don't chew.
He directs when the congregation speaks.
Of course,
plainview resists,
but Eli subjugates him.
He has to respond to as directed by Eli.
What do you want me to show you?
Life forces him to say exactly what he
wants and what he's insecure about.
I have a bend in my child
and in a complete reversal,
Eli speaks as the voice of God
throughout.
While we focus on plain,
it's a total opposite to the last
confrontation you like,
gives him the lines and he has to recite
them,
forcing plainview to for the first time,
lose his vocal control.
The next time they see each other is at
the end of the movie.
Even though Eli asks for help in this
scene,
he still starts off in control.
The camera follows him and he asserts
himself by making them drinks.
When plain view agrees to work with him,
he says he'll do it on one condition.
I'd like you to tell me that you are to
have been false prophet
because God is a superstition and now
playing view is the director.
Again.
No,
put your glass down.
In theory,
plainview has bested him,
but it doesn't really feel like a John
Wayne kind of local control.
I did watch
beach.
It's a bastardized version because at
the end,
plain winds,
but he's not in control.
He spirals completely out of control.
Towards the end,
he phones from the mouth,
stutter,
screams,
and grunts.
He loses mastery of everything in this
scene.
Even his walk,
when we think of John Wayne's grace,
it's also in his walk.
Plainview stumbles around incomplete,
erratic,
chaotic,
yes.
He doesn't have control at all.
Another relationship that showcases his
lack of vocal control is with his
adopted son,
hw at first do they work together as
partners,
but when he becomes deaf,
they lose their ability to communicate
and in short,
plainview doesn't know what to do with
him.
He's no longer an asset to the company
in plainview,
sends him away years later,
hw returns with his translator,
and plainview tries to control him
vocally by forcing him to speak,
becoming threatened when he considers
how a competitor you speak instead of
your little dog wolf,
full,
full.
So again,
he gets vocal control,
but at what cost?
It's cruel and doesn't feel like mastery
in a lot of what he says.
Daniel plainview may have the vocal
influence,
but he's a con man.
In one of his monologues,
he elegantly talks about the schools,
he'll build the wheat,
he'll grow and the importance of family
values,
but the visual show only men and no
school's irrigation or farmland,
just people preparing the drilling.
His Voice of God authority tricks us
even though plain view constantly talks
about bringing wealth to the town,
there are actually very few signs of him
improving the town.
There's a sort of false sense of control
when he talks.
He vocally controls Eli,
but not himself.
He can't vocally control his son because
he lost his hearing,
but he tries anyway and he can't control
the work he does.
He has to lie about the benefits of his
drilling and much of the dangers of
worker out of his control.
We expect playing views monologue to be
true because narrators are supposed to
guide the story.
One John Wayne movie that follows these
principles of narration is Red River,
which has a monologue that's almost
identical to plain views.
If you replace oil drilling with cattle,
good hungry people to make them strong,
make them grow.
The key
difference though is that John Wayne's
hypermasculine advertisement of his
cattle business is actually taken
seriously,
whereas there will be blood codes plain
view as a fraud.
John Wayne's movie seemed to have some
unrealistic ideals for heroes,
whereas there will be blood shows,
the more sinister sides of being in
control,
and I know I said John Wayne always has
vocal control,
but even he loses it in some of his
later movies that says
this chaotic shooting of Buffalo sheds
light on the darker side to his
supposedly mastery.
Regardless,
many of his earlier films create an idea
of a hypermasculine male with complete
control of what they say and how they
say it.
There's a certain fantasy to sounding
like John Wayne Chandler and the easy
way you'll learn the hard way,
but movies like there will be blood
bring into question the validity of such
a one dimensional kind of control.
Having such vocal authority actually
doesn't end well.
If someone really had as mainly a
dominion over their world,
they wouldn't end up like a cool suave
John Wayne riding into the sunset.
They'd probably become the erratic,
miserable and lonely Daniel plainview
because at the end of the day,
the old western heroes aren't real.
That level of mastery is not only
unrealistic but also dangerous.
Think about it.
Why couldn't Daniel,
plainview have let Eli Sunday give that
speech?
What difference does it make if he gave
his little blessing?
Daniel plainview explains it himself.
I have a competition,
no one else to succeed,
and maybe that hypermasculine
unfaltering thinking is no way to live
and no fantasy to strive towards.
Never Apologize,
Mr. to sign of weakness.
When studying voice John Wayne makes for
a great place to start.
His way of speaking is hyperbolic and he
represents the ability to vocally master
a scene.
His purest vocal power,
however,
feels unrealistic in dangerous when
studying more vocally complicated
characters.
One can use John Wayne's power as a
starting point and see how a character
succeeds in the John Wayne level of
vocal control and how they fail.
Do they control the camera?
Do they control the narrative and do
they control others,
and also at what cost?
Thanks for watching.
This video is brought to you by
skillshare.
Skillshare has thousands of courses
designed to help you learn a new skill,
whether you want to learn how to write
or how to create video,
they have some great options.
For example,
if you want to start writing,
take this course by author Emily Gould.
That'll get you on the right track.
If you want to start creating videos,
get good at it before investing in
expensive equipment.
Checkout Maddie Brown's course on low
budget filmmaking.
Actually just signed up for their after
effects for beginners course because I
want to incorporate it into my youtube
videos.
So far it's been super helpful.
Premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to learning,
but the first 700 members who clicked
the link in the description,
we'll get two months for free.
These spots are going to go quickly,
so make sure to be one of the first few.